- [Narrator] So in previous videos
we talked about the claim that if
I have two random variables, x and y,
that are independent, then the variance
of the sum of those two random variables
or the difference of
those two random variables
is going to be equal to
the sum of the variances.
So that if you have independent
random variables, your variation
is going to increase when you take
a sum or a difference.
And we've built a little
bit of intuition there.
What I wanna talk about in this video,
it's really about building
even more intuition,
is get a gut feeling for why this
independence is important
for making this claim.
And to get that intuition, let's
look at two random variables that are
definitely random variables but that
are definitely not independent.
So let's let x is equal to the number
of hours that the next person you meet,
so I'll say random person,
random person slept yesterday.
And let's say that y is equal
to the number of hours that same
person was awake yesterday.
And appreciate why these are not
independent random variables.
One of them is gonna
completely determine the other.
If I slept eight hours yesterday
then I would have been awake for 16 hours.
Or if I slept for 16 hours then I
would have been awake for eight hours.
We know that x plus y, even though
they're random variables, and there
could be variation in x and there could
be variation in y.
But for any given person, remember,
these are still based on that same person.
X plus y is always going
to be equal to 24 hours.
So these are not
independent, not independent.
If you're given one of the variables
it would completely determine
what the other variable is.
The probability of getting a certain
value for one variable is going to
be very different, given what value
you got for the other variable.
So they're not independent at all.
So in this situation, if someone said,
let's just say for the sake of argument,
that the variance of x,
the variance of x is
equal to, I don't know,
let's say it's equal to four,
the unit's four variance so
it would be squared hours.
So four hours squared.
We could say that the standard deviation
for x in this case would be two hours.
And let's say that the variance,
let's say the standard deviation of y
is also equal to two hours.
And let's say that the variance of y,
variance of y, well it would be the square
of the standard deviation.
And so it would be four hours,
four hours squared would be our units.
So if we just tried to blindly say,
"Oh, I'm just gonna apply this little
"expression, this claim we have,"
without thinking about the independents
we would try to say,
"Well then, the variance
"of x plus y, the variance of x plus y
"must be equal to the
sum of their variances."
So it would be four plus four.
So is it equal to eight hours squared?
Well that doesn't make any sense.
Because we know that a random variable
that is equal to x plus y, this is always
going to be 24 hours.
In fact, it's not going
to have any variation.
X plus y is always gonna be 24 hours.
So for these two random variables,
because they are so connected.
They are not independent at all,
this is actually going to be zero.
There is zero variance here.
X plus y is always going to be 24.
At least on earth where
we have a 24 hour day.
I guess if someone lived on another
planet or something it
could be slightly different.
And we're assuming that we have
an exactly 24 hour day on earth.
So this is to give you a gut sense
of why independence matters
for making this claim.
And if you have things
that are not independent
it gives you a good sense for why
this claim doesn't hold up as much.